Das war's für heute.
Ready to go!
Du kannst jedes audio interface im endeffekt auch das sein ganz nett mit kabel mit kabel skippt alles mögliche mit kabel hast du natürlich
wo ich ja großer fan von bin ist immer noch die die mx 300 das ist so für mich immer noch das beste was es gibt
allerdings auch das teuerste dragon force ja heute muss ein bisschen ich habe aus versehen gesagt italienischen italienischen
power metal aber es ist gar nicht britischer power metal also wenn man mal wireless hatte
aber das stimmt das stimmt nicht ich habe einen wireless kopfhörer und ich habe überhaupt keine
probleme mit meinem mx 300 aufzusetzen was auch noch gut ist sehend
wie heißt das ding von sein heiser sein heiser pc irgendwas aber als leistungsmäßig sind sind
mittlerweile glaube ich steelseries headsets ganz okay oder die was war das q pad war das
der q pad wie hieß dieses eine ding ich habe es vergessen ja also die steelseries ding als
im mittlerweil tatsächlich auch ganz brauchbar astro würde ich mit also kabel geboten wurde
mein wireless keine ahnung ich habe echt keine ahnung aber ich muss ehrlich sagen ich habe
mobile ja auch nen bose dings irgendwas was ist das überhaupt ich sag dir was was ich mobile
habe ich habe ich bin ja eigentlich hier quite komfort genau diese dinger ich bin ja eigentlich
sonst kein großer großer bose fan also dinger das sind die glaube ich die habe ich immer vor
einer weile gekauft hyper x meine ich genau ich glaube x meine ich und die sache ist die
die sind für das wofür sie für sie gemacht sind nämlich neues cancelling unterwegs sind
die dinger unschlagbar geil ich würde mir die aber nie vom pc zum spielen anziehen erstens
schwitzen die orten wie sau ja 260 aber das neues cancelling ist auch wirklich das beste was du
kriegst ja hier king halle die würde ich mir auch nie zum zum spielen kaufen dinger du schwitzt
du schwitzt wie sau drinne und neues cancelling ist beim spielen jetzt auch nicht grad so das
beste vielleicht willst du ja ein bisschen was von der umgebung mitkriegen außer dem ist es jetzt
nicht so dass du daheim grundsätzlich neues cancelling brauchst aber warum es mir hier ging war der
punkt weil jemand gesagt hat wer einmal wireless haben will der will keinen will kein kabel
kopfhörer mehr und das finde ich gar nicht benutzt die dinger hier ziemlich viel auf der
arbeit wenn ich mir ein bisschen krach ist aber daheim setz ich mir immer wieder mein
mx 300 auf weil mx 300 einfach beste ist das für ein ding ihr badi ihr badi was das senheiser hat
aber auch damit dass die dinger gaming technisch aussehen müssen oder das sieht aus wie irgendwie
so ein kran an der baustelle aber nicht wie ein headset was mit den los guckt euch das mal an
es soll eine soundkarte sein das sieht aus wie ein torpedo oder ein u-board
war ganz davon abgesehen gaming ein gaming also leute merkt euch es gibt auch gaming digital
analog konverter wusste gar nicht dass man digital analog konverten auch mit rgb kann
oh ich habe subs bekommen moment ich habe es voll übersehen x-masse twitch prime drei
monate erster das ist richtig du warst tatsächlich der erste big brain IQ steigt weiter mittlerweile
kann man das ja schon gar nicht mal auf eine zeile schreiben so ist der chat IQ
roffel eins vier drei vier vier monate big brain subs wieder jetzt kommt der flow 690 auch
noch mal vier monate twitch prime da freue ich mich dass ihr alle am start seid ja ich habe die
letzten tage bisschen weniger zeit gehabt wie gesagt meine mutter ist im krankenhaus ich
habe es ja wer mir auf glitter folgt der hat ja wahrscheinlich mitgekriegt dass wir eben dass
wir freitags in der nodraufnahme waren um 23 uhr um null uhr dann irgendwann wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich wird sie morgen oder übermorgen entlassen und ich wusste mich da letzt ich muss
hier ein bisschen ein bisschen euch machen ja und da muss ich suchen fahren also ich hatte
ehrlich gesagt auch keinen großen cocktails videos zu machen oder streamstellen zu machen
deswegen habe ich gestern abend auch kein aufwach stream gemacht gute beste ja da ist
brauner marok ich habe irgendwas von dir auf twitter gelesen wo ich mir gedacht habe da muss
ich mal was zu sagen ich weiß aber nicht mehr was es war also chat ihr seht ihr werdet ihr werdet
hardcore beobachtet na ich kann nix ihr könnt nirgendswo was machen ohne dass ich das mitkrieg
war das denn kann das sein kann das sein dass du dass du geschrieben hast dass die maps in
modern warfare scheiße sind aber das ist nicht das problem ist sondern die spieler die so sehr
kämpen oder sowas in der richtung ich habe irgendwas von dir gelesen wo ich mir gedacht
habe da muss ich was zu sagen gibt tatsächlich ein par dachs mit gaming features ernsthaft
wie darf ich mir das vorstellen wie kann ich digital analog konverten für gaming das habe
ich schon nicht aber ich lasse mich ja gerne eines besseren belehren so ist es ja nicht
der hook ist am start drei monate big brains ab exzellent exquisite
exzellent
high fat wine exzellent so wenn haben wir als nächstes ralle 2k twitch bleiben dankeschön
der erste monat ja ich hoffe dir gefällt blood pack 81 twitch prime jetzt gehts aber los hier
zum beispiel bass raus ja aber bass raus ist ja nix was ich mit nem dach mache was
raus ist es eine equalizer geschichte ja genau das hast du geschrieben habe gemeint die spieler
sind doch schuld wenn die so kämpfe spielen ja das das habe ich mir das habe ich mir gemerkt
weil dazu wollte ich extra wollte ich nämlich mal ein video machen also falls ich ein video
dazu mache liegt das an deinem kommand und zwar das lese ich nämlich öfter so nach dem motto was
kann denn das spiel dafür wenn die leute so sehr kämpen und ich denke das liegt natürlich auch an
den leuten wenn die so sehr so krass rum kämpft aber das game hat immer einen großen anteil mit
weil so wie das spiel gemacht ist spielens die leute also ein spiel kann die leute dazu
verleiten um zu kämpfen oder wie beispielsweise quake live eben die leute belohnen fürs rumlaufen
und das meine ich anscheinend nicht gekämpft wurde auch in mw2 vor zehn jahren ja aber
aber weit nicht so krass und das liegt am auf nicht nur an den maps das liegt generell am aufbau
von dem game ja low frequency boosting das hat aber mit dem dak nichts zu tun das ist
irgendwie equalizer geschichte oder besser gesagt irgendein irgendwelche frequenzie cuts
oder was auch immer aber das hat nichts mit digitaler locon verrat oder besser gesagt mit
dem digital locon verrat ja genau das das meine ich low pass high pass bei ja das stimmt das kann
man da machen was flashbacks größter kämpfer an der zeit oh ja
ja ja es ist schon klar jede sound card hat einen dak drinnen wie soll das
von hören ist halt analog ich glaube ist von ich glaube von uns hört noch keiner digital
gibt es eigentlich feifert wine schon fertig das brauche ich feifert wine auf spotify
what the fuck warum gibt es auf spotify feifert wine
ach das ist klasse aber das muss das ist geil das muss ich noch mal speichern
das ist aber nicht feifert das ist eher zu hat das ist ungedreht ich bräuchte das
ganze jetzt noch transparent gibt es das gibt es das transparent feifert wine ich brauche
ich brauche transparentes feifert wine für man für image overlay jetzt nicht ich mach
dir transparent ihr sucht einfach feifert wine in google und und nimm nimm das da oder so und
mach einfach transparent warum das wäre sehr nice kann ich das gleich in mein image in mein
image board reinhauen weil da haben wir aktuell nur noch den normalen feifert was prockt er da
das ist das fertige tool das fertige hardware tool im hintergrund ich wollte noch ein zwei
kleine sachen einbauen dann kaufen wir noch ein paar oder wir gucken mal ein paar dinge
nach auf aliexpress und eigentlich ehrlich gesagt mache ich auch bloß stream weil ich
erstens schon eine weile ich gestreamt habe gerade irgendwie so spontan bock hat zu stream
sollen und warum läuft meine vorschau wie sauer was da los losten wir frames oder so
wir losen keine frames ich glaube meine vorschau spackt einfach nur rum ich wahrscheinlich gar
nicht da dran naja was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen ja ich wollte einfach mal wieder stream
sollen und ein bisschen ablenken ich bin da froh wenn ich wieder aus dem krankenhaus draußen
ist dann ist wieder alles so dann ist wieder alles gut und dann ist wieder alles gut und
hat sich erledigt ich will nur ein paar kleinigkeiten auch bei dem tool einbauen 187 ja pock exzellent
exzellent heute iq so hat jemand was hat jemand erfahrung mit dem portierungsverfahren von
vdsl von o2 auf telekom habt ihr tatsächlich ein ganz gutes angebot von telekom äh ne aber
normalerweise musst du dich da doch überhaupt nicht drum kümmern oder das machen die doch
für dich
geht mich eh erst zufrieden wenn ich 420 viewer hab 100 100 cent waffle 1436 we are number
one oh ne das werde ich jetzt nicht spielen aber du kannst dir was anderes aussuchen wenn
du willst irgendwas headbanger mäßiges
hast du jetzt schon spotify ausprobiert nach amazon musik nein noch nicht aber es nervt
mich dass also ich ich werde definitiv amazon musik nicht verlängern kann ich sein dass
die hälfte von meinen playlists die songs nicht da sind und sie haben die ärzte vor
einem jahr oder so haben sie es riesig angekündigt ja die erste sind jetzt bei amazon musik
jetzt die hälfte weg was soll das sein was blödsinn
ja hören ist leider immer noch äh ziemlich analog genauso wie sehen das sagt halt eigentlich
wenn man es mal genau genau nimmt ne du musst dann beispielsweise erst mal digital analog
also wenn man es dir so überlegt wenn du dir so einen wenn du das mal anguckst wie
das beispielsweise bei der ps3 noch gewesen ist mit so einem fernsehen da wurde das dann
irgendwie 5 mal umgewandelt von der ps von der ps3 in analog an dem fernsehen von dem
eingang von analog wieder auf digital und dann wieder über über über so vertonen
in die augen rein und dann im hirn das war voll voll wir ja eigentlich eigentlich müsste
man mal endlich damit anfangen dass man sich direkt den hdmi stecker in den kopf stecken
kann schon ein rollout gemacht auf was bezieht sich das jetzt genau
bei dem apple stream ja bei dem apple stream und auch übrigens wisst ihr was wir uns angucken
müssen nächste woche das muss uns nächste woche angucken bei dem apple stream waren
glaube ich 750 oder 800 leute da ne
moment mal kurz message schreiben
so
komm im chat übrigens überhaupt nicht hinterher
spotty verschaffel ist kaputt jedenfalls fast 19.000 songs drin und kommen über die gleiche
ok wäre natürlich kacke wenn ich jetzt amazon music weghau und dann spotify genauso sagt
schon mal ein rollout in deiner ausbildung gemacht was
was soll ich ausrollen die quickscope header
ich glaube das habe ich da sogar drinnen
ich schreibe sie mal auf beste ich komme echt gerade mit dem chat hinterher
die falsche textnatei haue ist eine kacke
hat alles ok
ach sagt mal wann kommt denn eigentlich das trending aus
ich sehe schon wir brauchen heute keine keine zeile oder so wenn das so weiter geht vielleicht
soll ich besser auf just chatting umstellen aber es ist ja auch chill so proggers ja dann
kann da kann keiner sie auch
kommt denn das raus
8 november das ist ne über nächste woche
da nächste woche nächste woche ist das nächste woche wird da tot angeschwemmt
ach das meinst du matrix 1337 also der matrix 1337 wissen ob ich schon mal alle pcs in
einem unternehmen durch neue ersetzt habe nein habe ich noch nie habe ich auch gar
nichts mit zu tun
zum glück pc support ist nicht das wo ich bock so wirklich lust drauf hab
kann ich nee hab ich nicht gemacht
offener boy im roten shirt kommt wieder auf die bühne ja hoffe ich auch da war letztes
jahr nicht da aber letztes jahr war war das auch ziemlich ziemlich armselig so auf der
blitzcon
wer den typ nicht kennt es gibt bei den fhq sessions zu world of warcraft gibt es immer
so den übelsten lore also world of warcraft hintergrund geschichtenkenner der fragt ihn
der fragt ihn dann immer ganz abgedrehtes zeug so nach dem motto ja also leute ich hab
gesehen im neuen im neuen gebiet xy im fünften dorf steht ein npc der hat den gleichen nachname
wie der npc aus der hauptstadt allerdings im im im dritten kapitel vom neuesten buch
steht drinnen dass die nicht miteinander verwandt sind und wie kann es sein dass der npc da
steht so sachen fragte die dann immer und das hat ihn schon irgendwie ein bisschen berühmt
gemacht mittlerweile
haben circa 500 pcs mit baramundi aufgespricht gar nicht was das ist ich denke nach irgendeiner
provisioning geschichte
blitzcon eher schisscon excellent joke
ja also das müssen wir uns dann angucken das ist glaube ich am freitag um 19 uhr die
opening ceremony und ich rechne mit overwatch free to play overwatch 2 und vielleicht diablo
4 wobei ich ganz ehrlich mal sagen muss leute die haben es für mich mit diablo 3 so verkackt
und nachdem es mit pass of exile jetzt schon seit jahren
denn finde ich konkurrenzlos gutes free to play hack and slay action rpg gibt mit ziemlich
fairem bezahl modell weiß ich nicht wie es da so um die existenzberechtigung von diablo
4 eigentlich steht
wie gefällt ihr bisher konnte also ich habe außer das was wir im leider konnte ich ja
nicht was wir bisher im stream gespielt haben nichts weiter ich habe nicht eine minute multiplayer
gespielt wie gesagt ich bin mit meiner mutter in die notaufnahme gefahren am freitag abend
und ich habe keinen anschlag call of duty bisher gespielt das neue außer vier stunden
die kampagne hier im stream
du hast ja letztens tv headend installiert mit welchem klein kann ich das auf meinem
fernseher anschauen brauche ich da einen extra receiver für nee nee nee nee oder kann das
der fernseher out of the box achso nee nee also naja kommt drauf an es kommt drauf an
wenn du den halbwegs aktuellen fernseher hast von sagen wir mal von sony und ich glaube
auch von samsung also wenn du einen android auf deinem fernseher hast was sie immer mehr
haben dann ist kein problem dann ist alles mit dabei und beziehungsweise kannst du die
sachen aus dem app store nachinstallieren hast du einfach nur einen relativ simplen
ja fernsee als fernsee dann brauchst du noch irgendeinen günstigen stick aber da kannst
du einfach dann nimmst du einfach den firestick irgendwie sowas den firestick oder machst
kodi drauf mit tv headend und kannst gucken gibt auch ein paar alternativen es muss es
muss kein schild tv sein schild tv ist zwar finde ich immer noch mit das beste oh es gibt
neue schild tv oh das müssen wir uns jetzt mal kurz durchlesen gibt neue schild tv es
muss es muss aber halt kein schild tv sein weil schild tv ist halt eigentlich nicht
teuer es gibt neue schild tv es wusste ich gar nicht ist deine rot software immer noch
nicht fertig doch die ist fertig also bescheuerte frage aller außerdem ist software prinzipiell
nie fertig das wurde heute für den pc ach echt ok
ich voll hinten dran bin mit dem chat
gibt ihr mal barramundi ist schon eine krasse software ist das oder mal
ja ok das ist so ein provisioning ding was ist eigentlich jetzt weil es gleich plus
kondens was ist eigentlich aus diablo e portal geworden oder auch genannt im mobile
das die seite
dass das immer noch da ist
ich glaube nicht dass das noch rauskommt irgendwie mal ganz mal ganz unabhängig davon dass ich
auch bescheuert fanden dass sie das letzte plus kon angekündigt haben
an sich an sich ist den mobile diablo keine schlechte keine schlechte idee aber wie sie
das den leuten verkauft haben ist nackt das ist echt bescheuert die hätten das so die
hätten die skyrim beziehungsweise die die elder scrolls taktik machen müssen die hätten
einfach den leuten ankündigen müssen hey leute es gibt das in die mobile diablo vielleicht
nicht ganz so übertrieben wie sie es angekündigt haben dass die haben damit getan als kommt
jetzt hier das neue als haben sie das rad jetzt erfunden oder so und die hätten einfach
am ende zeigen müssen so nach dem motto 20 sekunden trailer in der azubi zusammengeschnitten
hat wo einfach die abloh 4 auf ploppt und gut ist
weil ganz ehrlich die idee von dem mobile diablo ist ja nicht schlecht aber so wie sie
es halt präsentiert haben wo ich weil sie denken sie komplett so detached von von der
fanbase irgendwie ich mein überlegt euch mal wer geht auf die blizzcon geht der 0815
mobile casual spieler auf die blizzcon fliegt da vielleicht sogar in die usa für eine blizzcon
und miete dass ich dann hotel holt sich tickets übernachte da nimmt sich urlaub der mobile
diablo gamer garantiert nicht wer dort auf die blizzcon geht ist hardcore blizzard fan
und die sind halt in der regel nicht auf dem pc die sind halt in der regel nicht auf dem
smartphone sondern auf dem pc an sich ist es keine schlechte idee in mobile diablo naja
gut wir gucken wir gucken uns das mal kurz alles gibt ein neues schiel tv mit netflix
button jetzt mit netflix button ok das schöne ist wissen was das gute am schiel tv ist
dass im endeffekt einfach ein stink normales android drunter ist deswegen kann ich einfach
auch wenn das offiziell mit sicherheit wieder nicht supportet wird deswegen kann ich einfach
meine buttons remappen habe ich aktuell mit dem markt mit der aktuellen schild mit dem
aktuellen schild tablet habe ich das nicht was erzähle ich für einen scheiß heute das
ist heute ist echt so so brain lag angesagt mit dem alten schiel tv habe ich das auch
gemacht habe ich auch die buttons remappt ein bisschen wie viel der button wohl gekostet
hat weniger als ninja auf mixer excellent aber warum sieht es jetzt aus wie ein zäppchen
auf einmal warum ist es nicht einfach wieder normale box oder shroud ja es ist ja es sind
ja noch mehr mittlerweile nicht nur shroud es ist nicht nur nicht nur ninja sind es sind
ja noch mehr mittlerweile man kommt ein exklusives angebot für mixer das lohnt sich für mich
nicht weil mein stream mit sagen wir mal 100 bis 300 zuschauer so schwankt immer ein bisschen
da bieten wir zu wenig für als dass es sich lohnt weil insofern die scheiße ist wenn
du auf mixer gehst das ist ja nicht jetzt für die reichweite irgendwie großartig geil
ich glaube was hatte ninja zuletzt 900 9000 viewer oder so und der hatte ja mal als der
mit drake oder was was drake oder als er mit dem gestreamt hat war das irgendwie noch 120.000
oder so das ist das ist einfach der deal für die rente das wird bei shroud nicht viel anders
sein das ist nicht für die für die masse an viewer das ist einfach so der deal für
die rente wenn ich mir belege die kriegen dann irgendwie was weiß ich 20 30 million
ich habe keine ahnung was ninja da gekriegt das wird ordentlich sein da ist vorbei was
jetzt los chat the fuck excellent chat excellent was ist was ist passiert riga raiden 290 personen
dankeschön nice excellent 5 hat was macht eigentlich dass das 5 hat ein bild ich habe
gesagt ich geht mich erst damit zufrieden wenn ich 400 wenn ich vor 20 viewer heute
habe es kann ich eigentlich oft gehen zahl ich vor 20 viewer mehr sogar high IQ richtig
high IQ heute hier wahnsinn ja also leute wie es dann streamtitel schon sagt machen
wir heute nicht wirklich irgendwie was großartiges wir programmieren ein bisschen an einem tool
weiter und dann wollte ich eigentlich ein bisschen zeug einkaufen was ich für meinen
technik bisschen technik krams auf aliexpress und mit dem chat labern das ist eigentlich
alles und irgendwie sind wir jetzt voll vom thema abgekommen und gucken uns gerade die
plus con schedule an und haben festgestellt dass wir ich glaube 19 uhr ist das warum warum
gibt es eigentlich zeitzonen 07 p.m. CET also moment ist was also ist schon ein moment das
ist schon die richtige zeit ok vergiss es das ist ja schon sommer das ist ja schon
dings hier zentral europ time 17 uhr 19 uhr passt schnell auf geborgs job das ist dragon
force ja so mags was muss ich bei aliexpress kaufen jetzt kommt drauf an was du machen willst
also ich kaufe jede menge technik klein kram auf aliexpress aber ich weiß nicht in die
weils bei dir mit heim automatisierung aussieht aber du könntest next level du machst einfach
tauch automatisierung was er muss er muss ja mit der zeit gehen kann sein eigenes u-boot
mit esp 32 bauen gut und eigentlich wollten wir uns jetzt mal das neue schild schild tv
angucken weil ich habe gar nicht mitgekriegt dass es neue schild tv weil ich nicht ganz
kapiere ist warum warum ist es jetzt so zäpfchen style das neue schild tv ja das ist doch
schon mal was ja schon mal mit handyapp hast du einen hast du einen staubsauger robotter
damit fängts nämlich bei den meisten leuten an wenns ums thema heim automatisierung geht
die meisten leute kaufen sich siehste siehste ist dann ist doch schon mal ist doch der kunststein
ist gelegt jetzt musst du den staubsauger robotter bloß noch routen und flaschen mit
custom firmware dann bist du dann bist du dabei 900 iq ist dann angesagt und das ist jetzt
kein witz das haben wir wirklich mal im stream gemacht die staubsauger geflasht also benutze
den nicht mehr ok ja das ist auch das problem was ich bei mir habe wenn ich den bei mir
im arbeitszimmer drauf los lasse dann bleibt er hängen aber fürs wohnzimmer und den flur
und so ist er ziemlich gut aber nochmal dankeschön für den host danni 1846 twitch prime hi iq
danke für den sub muss mal gucken ich hab wahrscheinlich total viel übersehen mittlerweile
ich komm zu nix der wahnsinn raffi 5 3 2 1 haben wir noch am start auch da steht jetzt
leider nicht dabei ob du neu gesagt hast doch du hast neu gesagt ersten monat dabei dankeschön
raffi big brain richtig big brain ok also was haben die jetzt neu gemacht beim aktuellen
shield tablet du zockst auch auf der ps4 nur nee mach ich nicht ich hab nur die beta
auf der ps4 gespielt und also die modern warfare beta hab ich auf der ps4 gespielt
noch bevor es auf dem pc gab danach eigentlich nur pc und ich hab halt keinen handschlag
keinen handschlag getan aktuell im modern warfare ich muss mit meiner mutter auf die
lohnaufnahme fahren freitag 23 uhr kommt morgen oder so wahrscheinlich wieder raus und
ich hab echt keinen kopf da irgendwie call of duty mit was zu spielen ging mir voll auf
den keks aber was willst du machen ich hatte keinen kopf für hart 4 abonniert twitch prime
den haben wir noch panda blase der namen verwirrt mich jetzt und dann haben wir noch ja dankeschön
für die ganzen subs leute i bims mary twitch prime auch am start der chat ist heute sowas
von high iq da geht gar nichts da geht gar nichts also ich glaube so high iq chat hatten
wir selten ja platzt schon fast cute chat aber sowas von sowas von cute chat heute naja also
was haben die jetzt neu gemacht beim aktuellen shield tablet das wollten wir uns jetzt mal
angucken das kostet doch nie im leben 149 dollar bei uns endlich mal jemand das richtig
aussprechen kann ja ich poste ja auch zu lead time auf twitter also ich kann auch schon
lesen das wäre doch auch was das wäre doch mal was leute ich hab ich ich hab mir nämlich
schon lange überlegt ich würde gern mal so einen kleinen für den big brain weil ich
weiß ja und der chat hier und die leute auf twitter sind generell also absolut high iq
und nachdem ich in letzter zeit öfters mal wieder programmier streams mache wollte ich
mal so einen kleinen contest basteln wo die leute sachen einschicken können aber nichts
großartiges und mir ist bisher noch kein ordentliches thema dazu eingefallen und das wäre noch mal
was nennen nennen nennen text to lead speak gen generator das kann man machen so in wahrscheinlich
so 15 20 zeilen oder so und dann gucken wir mal wer den besten lead speak generator hinkriegt
warst du mal max fps naja mal gewesen ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu endgültig
ausgedrückt ja also das letzte video habe ich vor vier tagen hochgeladen ja programmiersprache
ist egal einsendungen jeder wie er will allerdings muss ich dazu sagen wenn er das in super exotischen
sprachen macht dann kann es durchaus sein dass ich es überhaupt nicht einschätzen kann
ob es gut oder schlecht ist also ich war ich war mal vor vier tagen zuletzt max fps das
ist richtig ich kann den sub button nicht drücken weil ich bin ich eingeloggt dachte
weil du bei twitch anders hast ja ich heiß bei twitch anders weil ich den account mal
erstellt habe bevor ich überhaupt auf die idee gekommen bin zu streben
ja so sieht es aus ich weiß ich weiß dass ich mich umbenennen kann aber ich lasse es
erst mal erstens kommen die leute quasi da es fehlt so ein bisschen die deppen also eins
muss man ja echt sagen das wird mir der chat wahrscheinlich bestätigen können die die
öfters da sind dass der idiotenanteil auf twitch wirklich verdammt gering ist und ich
glaube das liegt einfach auch daran weil die verbindung zwischen youtube und twitch so
nicht so hoch ist was findest du also ich finde auf twitch auf twitch gibt es kaum deppen
bei mir ist der chat ich hab ich hab den besten chat ja natürlich wenn ich irgendwie bei
knossi oder so vorbeigucke dann ist kein wunder das da im chat da die hölle los ist ja
das ist natürlich jetzt ist natürlich klar ich rede jetzt oder guckt bei xqc guckt bei
irgendwie bei irgendwie in x beliebigen großen wobei xqc ist schon so beknackt das finde
ich schon finde ich schon wieder lustig ja aber mir ging es jetzt ja auch mein chat und
mein chat ist finde ich echt top da kann man nix sagen cute chat nur die besten dieser
chat hat aber zu viele weeps ja die haben sogar schon geschafft dass ich hier komische
komische emotes habe die ich anzeigen lassen kann excellent emotes ja ok wir waren eigentlich
beim nvidia schild tv was kosten das aktuelle schild tv eigentlich da sind wir doch nie
mal in diesen preisregionen drin ja guck mal das aktuelle schild tv kriegst du 200 euro
das werden wir im leben nicht für 150 euro sehen das kostet wahrscheinlich dann hier
eher wieder 200 replace existent schild tv generation ok hat ein bisschen aktuelle tecra
dinger drin das ist jetzt aber eigentlich nicht so der burner weil das ist das gleiche
glaube ich wie in der in der in der neuen switch wobei ist die neue switch halt übelst
unter takte das ganze welcher song läuft im hintergrund irgendwie dragon force reasons
to live ich habe einfach ich habe das ist dragon force best of ohne ohne live ach du
hast 460 bestellt ok wie gesagt ich glaube das ist dass ich glaube das ist die gleiche
pewdie den neun neun neun neun switch drinnen ist bloß dass die switch das brutal übertaktet
untertaktet nicht übertaktet schwachsinn untertaktet nee ich glaube fabi moment ich glaube die
neue switch hat einen etwas neueren tecra chip aber die untertakten das ding und sparen
noch mehr strom deswegen kriegen sie auch mehr akku raus gut aber das ist jetzt nicht
so wild ehrlich gesagt ich meine es ist cool dass das ding 25 prozent schneller ist aber
man muss schon sagen das aktuelle schild tv ist für einen für einen smart tv sowas
von schnell ich habe den unterschied ich habe ja vor drei jahren oder so weiß ich zwei
drei jahren habe ich mir einen sony fernseher gekauft er hat auch schon enjoy tv drauf und
im prinzip sieht die oberfläche von dem sony fernseher und dem nvidia schild tv auf den
ersten blick exakt gleich aus das problem ist nur dass das enjoy tv auf dem sony fernseher
leckt wie sau wenn du da drinne rumzoomst oder irgendwie drum switch das ruckelt halt
und auf dem auf dem schild tv ist es einfach richtig weich und und muss alles zumal man
ja das stimmt schon klein rotti hat recht also was richtig cool ist ganz abgesehen von
den spielen die man halt direkt auf dem schild tv spielen kann ist die ganze shadow play
geschichte oder nicht shadow play wie heißt das diese remote play geschichte ist wirklich
nice vor allem wenn der pc im gleichen netzwerk steht wie schild tv da kann man mittlerweile
ich verstehe bis heute nicht warum sie das nicht mehr bewerben wenn man ein fernseher
mit 4k und hdr kann man auf seinem gaming pc mit diesem schild remote play 4k hdr streamen
an den fernseher obwohl der pc keinen 4k hdr monitor hat game stream genau das ist eigentlich
richtig big brain ja also du kannst quasi auf dem pc am fernseher was spielen was dein
pc gar nicht angeschlossen hat ich habe das mal ausprobiert ich habe beispielsweise mal
shadow warrior gespielt ist eines der wenigen games die hdr unterstützung hat und das sieht
in 4k mit hdr richtig geil aus viel besser halt auf dem pc und spiel zum controller gut
aber dafür braucht man die leistung nicht weil läuft eher auf dem pc und wird nur ans
schild tv streamt ja ja leddy d3 d3 das ist auch der grund warum ich den schild tv dran
habe weil der das android tv ist zwar es ist zwar eigentlich cool dass das sony und samsung
auch weil nicht samsung hat was anderes sony auf jeden fall dass die android tv ausliefern
aber das support von den hardware herstellern ist halt echt krotten schlecht da kriegste
wenn du glück hast kriegst du mal ein android update oder sowas das ist halt müll das problem
haben ja auch viele android smartphone hersteller die nehmen es ja mit updates auch nicht so
genau und das schlimme ist halt dass das das android tv im sony fernseh schon geleckt hat
seit release und sie haben riesengroße updates versprochen ja also ich meine ich habe mich
nicht darauf verlassen weil ich muss ich auch nicht habe man schild tv dran aber sony hat
riesen updates versprochen weil ich weiß ja ich weiß ja nicht ob ihr das wusstet aber
für hdr gibt es ja auch zwei konkurrierende standards weil fife hat excellent wieder wieder
es kann nicht einfach einen hdr standard geben das geht nicht gibt zwei so und der eine ist
ein bisschen älter und der andere ist ein bisschen neuer und sony hat versprochen sie
patchen den irgendwie nach diesen neueren standard das firmware update gab es bis heute
nicht also sony hat war schön ska mast an der stelle oder um nicht zu sagen aber ich
habe mir das ja echt nicht deswegen gekauft hdr inhalte ganz ehrlich ich weiß nicht wie
es bei euch aussieht hdr ist ist mit dem passenden bild material schon eine coole sache meinst
du hdr 10 und doll bewischt das kann sein ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie das heißt
ich glaube schon hdr ist eine coole sache wenn man wenn man aquarium videos guckt oder
oder irgendwie sowas einmal ehrlich leute wer von euch guckt viel hdr oder wer von euch
findet überhaupt genug hdr material deine oma krass next level oma guckt die sich dann
den hdr großer munte pilcher hdr edition haben wir auf netflix echt so viel also auf
pc haben nicht so viele spiele hdr aber wenn netflix viel hdr hat dann lohnt sich das
tatsächlich das ist cool lustig gar nicht da brauche ich ja noch ein zusätzliches abo
ich habe mich bisher immer ums netflix abo gedrückt ich meine ich habe genug anderen
mist an abos mittlerweile möchte ja jeder dass man abos abschließt dann brauche ich
wohl demnächst noch netflix abo wann kommt eigentlich das steam abo ok das nice so was
was haben sie sonst noch schönes neue neu ist übrigens leute falls ihr irgendwas los
werden wollt an mich dass ich das auch sehe das müsst ihr mit entwobblos machen weil sonst
über sehe ich das ich habe heute eh schon die hälfte im chat übersehen auch vorher
schon und jetzt jetzt noch mal noch mal hundert leute mehr die werden bei die emojis eingeblendet
du meinst hier in der stream vorschau in dem ich von steam steams den chat verwende ein
arduino ist kaputt das heißt ich kann jetzt nicht mehr duschen weil damit die elektronik
nicht geht die das ventil regelt ja ist eh überbewertet ich sage muss den teich oder
so aber du könntest ja also nicht den next level du könntest ja einfach so eine so eine
teichpumpe nehmen und dann kannst du dann eben quasi quasi im garten oder so outdoor
immer dusch nicht aliexpress ist schon gelaufen wir haben doch gar nicht angefangen haben
es gerade zu überlegt weil ich habe ja im garten den teich fischl drin aktuell den
verwende ich halt für ist halt da was mich da auf die idee gebracht weil wir haben das
so eine so eine pumpe dran die die luft in den also die luft rein pumpt dass das dann
nicht so voller algen ist und so und die könnte ich eigentlich noch mit einem esp steuern
auf die idee bin ich jetzt noch gar nicht gekommen also hat es schon wieder gelohnt heute der
chat selbst programmiert nein das ist dings hier streamlabs das ist ein fetcher service
das haben wir nicht selbst programmiert wir haben zwar einen twitch chatlogger programmiert
mal hier im stream allerdings nicht mit obs plugin spackhack twitch prime zwei monate
dankeschön prime subscriber wann geht es mit dem cod mv singleplayer weiter ich hoffe
morgen abend dass wir das morgen abend durchspielen können
also wenn morgen abend meine mutter aus dem krankenhaus kann dann habe ich da auch bisschen
um game schichten zu kümmern ich meine benutzt du ein ach so du meinst das hier du meinst
die overlay das ist das ist das ist hier mein selbst gebasteltes image board das haben wir
auch hier mal on stream programmiert und ein paar leute haben sogar schon eigene custom
emotes beigesteuert das kann sogar das kann sogar darf man nicht vergessen kann sogar
sogar eine suche du öfters in nächster zeit brauchen unterhaltungsmöglichkeit weil ich
bin gestern handgelenkt worden ich bin in letzter zeit relativ häufig und ja
sp webserver wer lässt den webserver auf seinem sp auf das ich weiß dass es geht aber
normalerweise ja nicht wo ist der cute mod das frage ich mich auch wo ist wo ist der cute
mod hin übersicht roborock voice packs ne kenne ich nicht wird das per hotkey ausgelöst
kannst du machen du kannst entweder hier steuerung l drücken habe ich paar emotes gebeindet
kann man dann so ein bisschen für also epilepsie warnung jetzt kann man per shortcuts was programmierst
du für art verratet kann ich gleich mal zeigen den wollten heute eigentlich wollten wir heute
den feinschliff noch verpassen aber irgendwie haben wir noch nicht angefangen du kannst
es aber auch in einem web interface anklicken und ich mache das hauptsächlich so dass ich
auf meinem zweiten monitor dieses web interface aufhabe und damit die sachen aus auslöse easy
ich habe dich mit easy angesteckt musst du oft sein ich sage euch leute diese ganze diese
ganze twitch zwitsch ja ich benutze das ich benutze das teilweise schon in echt also wenn
jetzt irgendwie einer was zu mir sagt was ich gut finde dann sage ich dann pock einfach
einfach random nach dem motto und hat es geklappt ja pock das ist eigentlich richtig
bescheuert ja als richtig hängen geblieben aber ich war nicht genau wenn ich das eigentlich
total beknackt aber ja ganz ganz ehrlich leute es gibt schlimmeres als ich gedanken darüber
zu machen was die restliche welt von einem denkt außerdem könnte man das problem ganz
einfach lösen ja also aktuell ist es ja so dass die restliche welt irgendwie mit unverständnis
reagiert wenn man sagt lull oder pock oder poggers oder oder jebaited jebaited ist auch
so eine sache das sage ich relativ oft in echt ja aber eigentlich könnte man das problem
ganz einfach lösen aktuell ist es so die leute sagen was willst du das checken das überhaupt
nicht ja die einfachste variant wäre ganz einfach das war jetzt absolut big brain satz
also die naheliegendste variante wäre eigentlich total einfach die gehen einfach zu denen hin
die emojis machen die also die den unicode standard also emojis sind unicode ja also
wir reichen einfach eine petition ein um alle twitch emotes in den unicode standard aufzunehmen
so wie das bei emojis auch passiert und dann also alle unicode kannst du beliebig viel
code das ist egal kann so viele bites sein wie du willst und das reicht aber wir machen
eine petition reichen wir ein alle twitch emotes die wichtigsten ffz emotes und die wichtigsten
wäre der twitch tv emotes und das hätten wir gerne alles als unicode genormt und dann
natürlich auch als image fonts in allen gängigen betriebssystemen und auf mobile was haltet
davon ich fände dass das müsste das müssten wir erstmal machen das wäre das wäre wirklich
white people happier das problem ist bloß dass wenn man das wirklich machen würde gucken
die die gucken die dich halt eher so an was willst du so würden die unicode leute gucken
ich weiß ganz ehrlich so wirklich viele sachen braucht man nicht wir bräuchten 500 neue zeichen
was sind 500 neue zeichen bei unicode ist nichts überhaupt kein problem setzt du das
durch aber sicher
wann würdest du sagen ist jemand junior beziehungsweise senior developer wenn es an seiner an seiner
stelle dran steht kann jeder normale bei unicode was einreichen ich muss dir ehrlich sagen
ich habe keine ahnung wie man sachen unicode standardisiert kriegt das mache ich auch
lenni das mache ich auch ich ich verwende auf discord auf discord geht es ja mittlerweile
übrigens übrigens ich habe eine discord server soll ich an der stelle mal erwähnen auf discord
haben wir ja die ganzen emotes aber ich verwende auch in allen möglichen chats und oder hier
auch ein message oder irgendwie sogar mittlerweile ich habe letztens ich habe letztens wieder
auf der arbeit irgendwelche gescheuten sachen ins ticket system gepostet was wahrscheinlich
wieder keiner gecheckt hat aber gut für die leute nichts verstehen die freuen sich wahrscheinlich
was habt ihr für ein ticket system wir haben wir haben hiera und es heißt hiera und es
heißt nicht dann denke ich auch immer hiera wer hat euch das erzählt dass es hiera heißt
das heißt hiera das heißt hiera weil es ja weil es von irgendwas japanischem kommt und
es sagt sogar unicode.org das sagt sogar der hersteller dass das inspiriert von irgendwas
japanischem ist und ganz ehrlich wenn die japaner sagt ihr hiera anstatt hiera wobei
so die japaner mit sagen hiera das klingelt wie viel japanisch also jif ja jif das sind
das sind die kleinsten oder noch schlimmer jubantu genau jubantu jubantu sowas hängen
gebliebenes die kann man warum naja ok was hinversinnt versteht man würdest du sagen
macht es sinn nach der ausbildung das unternehmen zu wechseln wenn es dir nicht gefällt also
ich sag mal so es muss man muss das nicht unbedingt machen also ich weiß dass viele
leute sagen so sagt jemand ja wenn du direkt wechselst dann kriegst du jetzt alter warum
krieg ich jetzt auf einmal so krass viele views the fuck hat mich noch irgendwer gehostet
oder so es hat gerade auf ein auf einen jump habe ich 100 100 neue views gekriegt was ist
da los jetzt ist jetzt ist wieder 100 weniger ok ich glaube ich glaube ich werde einfach
gebetet gebetet von von twitch ähm genau also zu dieser zu dieser ausbildungsgeschichte
ich würdest du es kieter ausbrechen denn dann spreche ich lieber jaira aus aber zu dieser
ausbildungsgeschichte und und betrieb betrieb wechseln also ich denke nicht dass das zwingend
irgendwie erforderlich ist also ich weiß es gibt viele leute sagen dass ja dann bist
du bist du geldmäßig gleich viel besser gestellt sonst war es weil man in seinem ausbildungsbetrieb
nie verdient ich bin der meinung das steht und fällt ganz einfach damit was man kann
und wenn man in dem laden ist wo es einem gefällt die einen auch behalten wollen und
wo man wo man auch irgendwie so so ein bisschen so in zukunft für sich sieht wozu warum sollte
man das wechseln nur weil irgendjemand irgendein beratungstyp sagt er ist viel besser wenn
man nur wenn du wechselt warum
frage weil wir verdrehen unser eigenes ticketsystem oh willst du mich bekehren zu eurem ticketsystem
ja das ist leider so dass so was wie ticketsystem oftmals eingeführt wird und dann wird es
halt stehen gelassen und es gibt es gibt auch auch noch leute die haben wie heißt das von
hp hp open view open view oder so die müssen sich immer noch damit rumquälen hast du heute
schon erzählt was man alles mit twitch prime machen kann ich habe heute keinen bock auf
sellout ich habe auch ohne sellout schon wieder ziemlich viele subs heute abgekriegt was
natürlich sehr nice ist 100 mal in stream geöffnet au exzellent wollte nicht freund
jemand nen pfeiffert wine bild machen transparent also ich will jetzt keinen dafür zwingen
hier kostenlos für mich zu arbeiten oder so aber wenn es heute freiwillig machen natürlich
schon nice ubot ja ich komme ich komme zu nichts gibt es bei euch noch cobalt programmierer
ja ja jetzt haltet euch mal fest wir haben sogar cobalt programmiererinnen und die sind
unter 35 sogar richtig hotte grills hab gehört hier gibt es heiße dotnet coweb anwendungstipps
heute vorgesetzt bekommen razor page etc verstehe nur bahnhof bis jetzt taugt das was jungs
razor pages taugen razor pages was also wenn du den indischer programmierer bist und auf
fiver für 6 euro 68 aufträge entgegen nimmst dann kannst du was in razor pages machen ja
razor pages kann man verwenden aber so wirklich verwendet wird es eigentlich doch selten
er ist informiert monka tos fack anzeige ist raus abmahnung ist raus oder muss pedalo kaufen
was warst du naja homeworld das ist das ist auch schon so ein bisschen übertrieben jetzt
sagt was du in drei wochen im rz lernst wirst du erst in fünf jahren studium lernen du lernst
komplett andere sachen du lernst im rz nicht wie du quicksort programmierst wenn du studierst
lernst du das aber schon also lernst du unterschiedliche sachen meinst du ein zentral das ist das
ist tatsächlich eine gute frage meinst du ein zentrales block management mit elastic
search und kibana meinst wahrscheinlich wäre ein gutes abschlussprojekt das ist eine
gute frage und zwar ich bin mir gar nicht sicher was lernst du denn was lernst du denn
welchen zwei lernst du weil die sagen nämlich ich glaube die haben nämlich auch irgendwo
auf ihrer webseite stehen was die was die haben wollen und zwar es gibt eine sache
wo man wo man wirklich drauf achten muss bei seinem abschlussprojekt und zwar ok scheiß
dran was auch immer die ihk da schreibt also was ganz wichtig ist du solltest nicht schreiben
wobei hast du paar informatik system integration ok du solltest nicht schreiben dass du ein
zentrales lock management mit elastic search und kibana baust das würde ich nicht schreiben
ich würde eher was schreiben in die richtung keine ahnung evaluierung zentraler lock management
systeme inklusive beispiel keine ahnung testung inklusive test umgebung irgendwie sowas weil
es geht also wo die ihk drauf steht ist dass bei der abschlussprüfung nicht gesagt wird
ich mache jetzt diese eine sache auch egal wie kompliziert die sache ist was die was
die wieder bei was sie bei der ihk immer toll finden ist wenn du wenn du sagst ich suche
eine passende lösung für problem xy und natürlich steht im vorfeld schon fest für
dich dass du elastic search machst aber das würde ich nicht reinschreiben genau marktanalyse
entscheidung zwar den scheiß musst du machen das ist zwar übelst räudig aber da stehen
die drauf ja genau dass sowas das auch macht und dann ist das mit sicherheit ein gutes
projekt du musst aber gucken du musst aber gucken dass du nicht zu viel machst weil wir
hatten sie glaube ich gerade wir hatten sie gerade auf die zeit ist jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig
groß ich mein guck mal du hast du hast 35 stunden das ist eine woche du hast eine woche
zeit für eine woche zeit für den abschlussprojekt du kannst in der woche also kannst keinem
ernsthaft erzählen von von den leuten bei der ihk dass du in der woche quasi evaluierung
machst den produkt aussuchen sich soweit in das produkt einarbeitest dass du dann noch
was was aufbauen kannst was funktioniert und und im großen stil genutzt wird das glaubt
dir keiner ja und übrigens was gekostet hat finden sie auch super interessant wenn du
das reinschreibst das ist genau das ist inklusive inklusive projektdokumentation bei der zeit
liegt man doch eh ja aber es ist ein unterschied ob du ein bisschen länger brauchst oder ob
du einfach projekt machst was wofür du drei monate brauchen würdest und ein zentrales
lock management was auch was auch wirklich eingeführt werden soll und halt funktioniert
das braucht länger als eine woche das dauert jetzt da reden wir eher im bereich von einem
halben jahr oder so aber deswegen würde ich reinschreiben du suchst du suchst eine zentrale
möglichkeit zum zentralen lock management oder zur zentralen lockverwaltung kommst
dann halt drauf dass elastic surge das beste ist was du verwenden kannst und machst irgendwie
so eine mini teststellung das reicht das projekt soll ja auch ein wirkliches projekt sein naja
da wird also ganz ehrlich soll ich euch mal sagen was ich als abschlussprojekt gemacht
habe ich hoffe ich hoffe ich komme noch ich krieg den titel noch irgendwie zusammen muss
mal kurz überlegen wie das hieß wie habe ich das genau beschrieben
so ich muss mir das gerade mal aufschreiben was mir passt und zwar ich habe als abschlussprüfung
gemacht das nannte sich ungefähr ich habe sie jetzt gerade noch mal so aus den fingern
gesagt wie es ungefähr hieß standortkopplung ich bin mir nicht sicher ob ich layer 2 vpn
reingeschrieben habe aber sind gemäß sowas wie standortkopplung mittels layer 2 vpn zur
transparenten anbindung von endgeräten das habe ich gemacht als abschlussprüfung und
das ist natürlich exquisite excellent five head wine und das projekt habe ich nie wirklich
gemacht ich habe es mir aus den fingern gesorgt und ich wollte das machen aber wir haben es
nicht gebraucht mehr ich habe das projekt rein rein fiktiv zusammen gefakt ja und meine
abschlussprüfung ist eh scheiße gelaufen weil ich in meiner abschlussprüfung durchgefallen
bin bevor ich die prüfung hatte das geht das das geht auch nur bei der ihk sowas
ja ein bisschen zeitverschiebung rein kannste auch machen meinst du denn vom umfang von
der komplexität wäre das ausreichend wie gesagt die komplexität von technischer seite
aus ist fast zweitrangig bei der abschlussprüfung wenn der umfang ist mehr als genug wenn du
wenn du allein schon allein schon die analyse und auswahl der produkte dauert er die hälfte
der zeit die doko dauert die andere hälfte der zeit da hast du nicht wirklich viel zeit
technisch was großartiges zu machen außer außer den dienungsserver hinzustellen und
das kibana drauf zu entzählen du darfst den aber nicht verkaufen dass das jetzt die fertige
lösung ist die die leute produktiv verwenden sondern du sagst das ist das ist eine teststellung
auf der jetzt weitere weitere keine ahnung sachen durchgeführt werden können ja die
aber nicht mal bestandteil von einem abschlussprojekt sind dein abschlussprojekt bezieht sich
da drauf dass du guckst was es gibt was auswählst und eine teststellung hinstellt womit dann
weitergemacht werden kann das reicht warum ja also naja gut ich habe ich das nicht schon
mal erzählt mit meinem abschlussprojekt also macht ja nichts im prinzip kann man das kann
man öfters erzählen ich hatte an dem tag wo meine ihk abschlussprüfung war hat mich
um um 10 uhr oder so ich habe lange geblieben war 14 uhr 30 war die war die angesetzte ihk
abschlussprüfung und was wird denn hier so gemacht ja eigentlich wollten wir was programmieren
und dann wollten wir aliexpress kaufen und mittlerweile sind wir bei ihk abschlussprüfung
gelandet und was auch immer ich mache jetzt einfach weiter weil ihr wisst ja ich bin der
meister im sidetracked werden genau und die abschlussprüfung bei mir war erst um 14
uhr oder 1430 und um 10 uhr klingelt das telefon und die frau von der ihk ist dran wohlgemerkt
meine abschlussprüfung war erst um 1430 und um 10 uhr ruft die frau von der ihk und klingelt
mich aus dem badge, gehe ins telefon und die sagt ja herr max sie sind durchgefallen
und dann habe ich dann ungefähr so geguckt und ich habe gesagt wie bin ich durchgefallen
meine abschlussprüfung war dann auch gar nicht wie kann ich durchgefallen sein wenn
meine abschlussprüfung noch gar nicht gewesen ist wie soll das funktionieren ja und dreimal
dürft ihr raten woran woran lag es angeblich die die es gemacht haben können sich wahrscheinlich
denken gerade die geschichte ganz von youtube ok es lag daran dass die ihk gesagt hat ich
hätte meine abschluss und meine projektdokumentation nicht eingereicht und warum habe ich doch
vor monaten schon gemacht ja und dann hat sich dann rausgestellt ich hatte sogar noch
die bestätigung email von der ihk dass das eingegangen ist bei ihnen und das problem war
wirklich dass der ihk server wahrscheinlich direkt nach meinem upload abgekackt ist ich
habe abgelaudet auf meinem projektdokumentation zu ihk die haben mir die haben mir eine bestätigung
email geschickt und dabei ist der ihk server abgekackt und meine projektdokumentation
ist weg ist ein ssh klein in chrome sinnvoll und wenn man es braucht schon ansonsten würde
ich ein echtes terminal nehmen so und daraufhin hat sie das dann in die wege geleitet dass
ich doch zur prüfung kommen kann und ich hatte dann halt einen riesen vorteil dadurch weil
die haben ein abschlussprojekt niemals gesehen vorher und die hatten auch kein interesse
daran mich jetzt zu ärgern weil sie mich die ihk schon genug geärgert hat und dementsprechend
hatte ich auch keine fragerunde beim abschlussprojekt ich habe das vorgestellt und das einzige was
die mich gefragt haben am ende ist ob es funktioniert hat habe ich gesagt ja gut funktioniert und
dann war fertig dann hatte ich das bestanden dazu kann ich nur sagen das war die easieste
abschlussprüfung die es überhaupt gegeben hat hast du erfahrung mit docker geht so aber
ich meine es ist ja nicht so dass es dass ich verkackt hätte ja in papierform das einzige
wo ich es in papierform gehabt habe war es dann ich habe es mitgebracht in papierform
zur abschlussprüfung weil ich es ja nicht sehen konnten vorher die konnten es ja nicht
sehen vorher die haben das zum ersten mal gesehen als ich da im raum gestanden habe
hast du danach noch ein studio gemacht einfach nach dem hochladen den server die das ist
das ist das ist wirklich next level das muss man einfach machen ja x-rays twitch prime
drei monate huge brain poggers ja war ja doch b29 korn twitch prime danke schön ach du hast
gewechselt von prime auf stufe 1 richtiger sub also kein kein prime sub sondern ein richtiger
slay dat teddy twitch prime dankeschön iq sub was übersehen doch spack hack habe ich
übersehen 3 sub zwei monate und purple habe ich auch übersehen oplos ist auch gut habe
ich aber glück gehabt da dankeschön für die ganzen subs alter kev teich jetzt der
massive big brain ja
wollten wir nicht auch mal ein ihk abschlussprüfung im stream schauen ja wollten wir aber die
sache ist die man darf die dinger nicht zeigen das ist monka toss xx fablus xx zwei monate
dankeschön sub der iq wird nicht so hoch der ist schon der ist schon der ist eigentlich
schon zu hoch damit das overflowed bald negativ
ja das stimmt jeder hat jeder hat eine abschlussprüfung aber es ist ein unterschied ob jeder sich
irgendwo von ich wollte gerade sagen von rapidscher von keine ahnung wo auch immer rapidscher
gibt es ja nicht mal so was zieht als wenn ich dem stream zeige hast du von dem 35 euro
show me smartwatch ist aber nicht nein surface tablets das ist tatsächlich mal ein microsoft
product wo ich sagen muss die sind echt surface tablets die haben auf der arbeit so ein riesen
so mehrere riesen surface hub dinger und das ist wirklich so ein teil da das ist wirklich
ganz cool muss ich sagen so dinger da das ist wirklich ganz cool das ist so ein teil
mit mit touch screen und was stifte nehmen kannst radieren obwohl es halt nur fake ist
du kannst dir die bilder dann später auch bei email schicken kannst leute hinzu leider
leider nur per skype was natürlich ein bisschen eklig ist kostet das nicht 20.000 euro ja
wie gesagt aber bei der bank die haben geld und wenn nicht können sie sich das für null
prozent zinsen leihen
ja ich habe leider kein surface book aber ich also das ist so ein ding was ich mir tatsächlich
eine der wenigen microsoft produkte wo ich sagen würde ich würde ich mir echt kaufen
was fdw nee nichts gemacht wollten wir uns nicht das schiel tablet angucken also was
haben sie denn neu beim schiel tablet schiel tv nicht schiel tablet schiel tv dolby vision
hdr content das ist natürlich big huge wir wollten vieles machen das stimmt aber wir
haben halt auch großes hirn da passt viel rein so physical design das juckt mich ja
ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht ok das schiel tv pro ist sieht aus wie die alte box und
das neu ist so ein komisches komisches zäpfchen ok mehr ram ja das ist schon mal ok mit verkehrt
gut das deutsch das ist jetzt fast wurscht ob mein ob mein schild 1080p streams transkoden
kann ist mir auch wurscht flexmedia surfer auf dem schild verwende ich ähnlich smart
flings würde ich im leben nicht verwenden dafür habe ich meine eigene automatisierungsgeschichte
mit home assistant usb 3.0 ports das ist auch nicht wozu das gut sein soll ai upscaling
oh aber ich aber ich hoffe ich hoffe mit blockchain weil ohne blockchain geht sowas
ja gar nicht mehr heutzutage die frage ist hier bei dem usb natürlich auch ist es usb
3.0 3.1 3.2 oder ist es gar usb 3.2 gen 2 mal 2 gen 1 gen 2 was verwenden die hier für
usb ports dann weiß es nicht usb 3 haben sie so verkackt die benahmung haben sie hardcore
verkackt aber richtig richtig pp gas ai upscaling made possible blablabla you might have heard
of upscaling bevor nein das hat bestimmt noch nie jemand gehört der sich irgendwie ein
bisschen mit fernseh beschäftigt upscaling ja das kann nicht sein da hat man noch nie
was von gehört and you even my think your tv handle standard macht er eigentlich auch
würde ich sagen ok hier man muss halt sagen das ist wirklich
ein riesen pluspunkt von dem von dem neuen nvidia schiel tv das abs oder man umgedreht
muss man sagen das ist ein großer negativ punkt vom alten schiel tv das 4k upscaling
ist absoluter crap beim aktuellen schiel tv das ist wirklich ja das ist richtig kacke
dass sie das bis dass sie das nie auf die reihe gekriegt haben weil ein ordentliches
4k upscaling in das alte schiel tv rein zu patchen ist schon eigentlich lächerlich gut
jetzt verkaufen sonst das neue schiel tv mit ai upscaling auch gut was natürlich viel
besser ist als bei einem aktuellen fernseh und sonst was es wird mir ehrlich gesagt
schon reichen wenn das aktuelle schiel tv was ich habe auch nur ansatzweise so gut upscaling
könnte wie man fernsehe also das 4k upscaling ist halt wirklich crap und 4k upscaling brauchst
du halt immer wenn du den 4k fernseh hast weil der kann halt nur 4k ausgeben oder aber
du fütterst ihn mit was unter 4k dann upscale er selber das pendel ist halt nun mal 4k da
kann man nichts dagegen machen on device 4k upscaling which is powered by on device machine
intelligence das ist richtig smart tv dann train on a deep neural network alter aber da
fehlt noch blockchain also blockchain es ist egal ob das was damit zu tun hat oder nicht
ohne blockchain kaufe ich das net
ja ok es kann quasi optisch schärfere bilder produzieren als was als der fernseh
schiel tv dolby vision dolby atmos ja ok das ist muss jetzt mittlerweile sein schiel tv
super zu bla bla bla bla netflix amazon prime video disney plus ist ne plus das ist auch
so ein abodienst den keiner haben wollte ich weil wenn man wenn man sagt man so wenn man
die star wars fände so mags vielleicht cool sein wenn da das neue zeug kommt aber so wirklich
so wirklich danach gefragt hat doch keiner oder hat keiner gesagt oh ja wir brauchen
unbedingt noch ein disney aber apple tv so es juckt mich überhaupt nicht ai upscaling
mich würde man ernsthaft interessieren was dann ob da wirklich so viel ai dran ist an
dem wie sie da so tun
ein video ist shipping new schiel tvs mit brand new redesigned remote ja das ding ich muss
sagen die alte end die alte schiel tv remote ist wirklich ein bisschen ein bisschen sehr
minimalistisch die da das ist die alte nee was ist das also das ist die alte die ist
doch ein bisschen sehr minimalistisch gewesen muss man sagen hier ist hier ist lautstärke
hoch und runter das ist so ein bisschen touch sensitive hier kannst du google assistant
anmachen das habe ich aber auch remap den button verwendet kein google assistant bei
mir hier kannst du halt so das sind halt die standard android sachen hauptmenü back und
steuerkreuz und ok fertig es reicht eigentlich der steam hollywood sale ist live ok wir kommen
heute wir kommen heute wahrscheinlich nicht dazu zu programm haben wow das ist mal eine
fernbedienung also die alte war echt ein bisschen sehr minimalistisch aber ich fand's
eigentlich ganz gut jetzt jetzt haben sie es halt so gemacht lauter leiser war bei der
alten war bei der alten in der mitte einen slider also im prinzip vorspulen zurückspulen
ist die sache starten stoppen gab es vorher auch schon kannst du einfach mit dem ok button
machen menü button gab es nicht menüs unterstützt aber auch android tv gar nicht
android tv unterstützt glaube ich gar keine menüs
ok was auch immer du wirklich brauchen tut man es ehrlich gesagt nicht start stoppt
so mit dem ok button in kodi machen spulen vor und zurückspulen konntest du total simpel
über das aufwander in kodi machen das ist hat aber noch irgendwie seine daseinsberechtigung
die buttons hattest du vorher auch schon das hattest du vorher auch schon ein an ausknopf
ja ok das ist tatsächlich ganz cool da muss ich nämlich mal vorstellen das ding hatte
vorher kein an ausknopf gibt es tatsächlich geräte die kein an ausknopf haben aber man
darf nicht vergessen das schiel tv schaltet sich eh nie aus das schaltet einfach nur
das licht aus das schaltet sich nie aus und netflix button an sich finde ich finde ich
ok warum warum nicht ja warum das jetzt so eine röhre ist ich ganz ehrlich ich finde
ich finde eine röhre ziemlich doof weil die röhre rollt rum oder du stellst die hochkant
aber du musst dir irgendwie netzwerkstecker rein machen willst du dann den netzwerkstecker
oben raushängen lassen weil du es auf den kopf stellst oder willst du es hinstellen
so dass der netzwerkstecker unten ist oder wie funktioniert das
wollen die dass man das hinten an das fernsehen macht oder naja also das abscaling ist tatsächlich
cool ich meine es hätte es hätte kein ai abscaling oder so sein müssen hauptsache
gescheites 4k 4k abscaling was das alte schiel tv nicht hatte ja schon am start halb stunden
ok leute ich glaube ich stelle mal die kategorie oft just just chatting um wobei warum das chatting
sind hier sind die bessere leute hier sind die ist cute am start ich glaube großartig
programmieren wir heute nicht mehr steam ist down steam ist down tatsächlich ergeben die
buchstaben die du immer markierst und kopierst irgendwann ein steam code das ist die frage
ja wenn ich das jetzt verraten würde wäre das nicht sonderlich big brain
home welder gäbe ich dir recht er schreibt in fünf jahren wird wieder rumgeheult wieso
die raubkopier szene gewachsen ist jeder muss unbedingt seinen eigenen scheiß streaming
angebot haben ja ja das war ja auch so der auslöser damals dass man halt ist den leuten
nicht in diesem medium auf dieser plattform geliefert hat wo sie es gerne hätten die leute
als also als sie alle noch cds verkaufen wollten wollten die leute halt auf ihrem computer
das als mp3 ist oder als digitale geschichten haben ja und da haben die musikindustrie
damals so naja wollen wir nicht das gleiche problem mit teilweise spielen film sonst was
oder hast ja heute noch mit serien die es nicht im originalton gibt oder mit sachen
die exklusiv irgendwo erscheinen und so ich glaube die meisten leute heute können es
tatsächlich bezahlen wenn es ist entweder in dem land gäbe oder wenn es nicht so ganz
abgedrehte sachen sind mit du brauchst 30 abos
die ist weg hat sich erledigt die weiß ich ob von einer pci karte pci du meinst pci express
oder treiber ins hilse unter linux oder welches def gerät es ist einfach das hier mal eingeben
und gucken ob du da was von siehst du kannst def dvb kannst du gucken def dvb in die ganzen
dinger im syslog kannst du gucken oder lspci-vv und siehst zumindest ob er das erkannt hat
los aliexpress ich hab hunger hab nix gegessen keine ipv4 adressen mehr zu vergeben haben
diesmal aber wirklich ich glaube wir müssen uns eine ganze weile mit carrier natt rumschlagen
ja glaube ich auch das problem ist ja auch dass eigentlich die provider die letzten sind
die diesen schritt vollziehen können es muss erstmal alles was angeboten wird ipv6
fähig sein dass den provider es wagen kann zu sagen wir verzichten auf ipv4 es muss alles
ipv4 unterstützen was aktuell ist es müssen alle sachen ordentlich mit ipv6 erreichbar
sein und erst dann können provider für endkunden wirklich sagen wir machen ipv4 nicht mehr
ordentlich thomas cool 110 twitchbein dankeschön
winforms tja manche sachen machst du am einfachsten den winforms das ist so ein super simples
ding was ich für hardware ad gebastelt hab wurde woran bestellungen drinnen erfassen
kann und dann nach den bestellungen suchen kann oder oder auch mit seinem scanner sachen
einscannen kann das war es das ist eine anwendung aus zwei forms und ein paar zeilen code behind
fertig da ist winforms halt am einfachsten
minus vv is very verbose ja also wenn lspci das ding nicht anzeigt dann stimmt was nicht
lspci sollte theoretisch alles zeigen hast du eine empfehlung für einen router access point
mit sehr guter reichweite ja auf jeden fall schon mal kein router access point kombi sondern
den access point und dann ist die frage wie und wo willst du beispielsweise deinen garten
anbinden und alles kommt von einer richtung dann kann man sich über so ein bisschen richt
schichten gedanken machen aber womit du eigentlich prinzipiell immer ganz gut fährst sind diese
dinger wo beide aber mal gucken muss die haben mittlerweile eine neue serie vielleicht sind
die auch besser mit den dingen kannst du eigentlich relativ wenig verkehrt machen aber die haben
jetzt keine also die haben jetzt keine größere reichweite als irgendwie normal möglich
ist da musst du schon mal nach speziellen antennen gucken besonders interessant natürlich
wenn du aus einer richtung das ganze nur benutzen willst also in richtung garten oder so dann
braucht es dann noch einen anderen access point den rest abdeckt aber die mit den dinger
kann man nicht allzu viel verkehrt machen hier kann schon mal gucken ob das funktioniert
was natürlich auch noch eine option ist falls du wirklich deinen garten anbinden willst
und und vielleicht die möglichkeit hast irgendwie ein bisschen outdoor was anzubringen da kannst
du ja auch ein outdoor access point holen ist auch nicht verkehrt
router natürlich ja ganz klar router also outdoor habe ich nur einmal so ein ding hier
in den händen gehabt wie gesagt ich bin auch mit netzwerks nicht großartig zu tun und
zwar ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung welche das davon gewesen ist
ich weiß nicht mehr keine ahnung du nutzt xfce oder nee ich benutze i3 nicht
gute murk ja heute mal headbang time gibt von unify eine auto antenne ja das ist doch schon
mal was und weil man halt sagen muss antennen die man quasi outdoor anbringt um sie dann
irgendwie ein access point in anzuschließen ist immer so eine sache weil das tödlichste
für reichweite guten empfang ist eigentlich das kabel zwischen gerät und antenne
teinser stufe 1 vier monate eierjahr
das ist
das lied ist so fire and flames von tragen force
eigentlich somit das bekannteste von denen es gab sogar schon das ist aber alt es gab
sogar schon damals in guitar hero guitar hero kloppt die serie gibt es gar nicht mehr oder
panzei stufe 1 vier monate aber ab hier da ich das iq overflow dann sind wir wieder
bei minus und 30.000 noch was aus welchem anime ist was weiß ich den chat hat gemeint
das brauchen wir als die maut wenn er sie bauri jetzt da wäre der könnte uns das sagen
ich habe gehört die access points von schaumier haben höhere reichweiten da die in asien
mit höheren frequenzen arbeiten und dann die frequenzen sind überall die gleichen sonst
wird es nicht funktionieren die können ein bisschen mehr leistung vielleicht dürfen
die einstellen ja also sie dürfen im endeffekt mehr sagt man das richtig ja mehr leistung
in die antenne pumpen quasi weiß gar nicht was hier die was hier die maximale sendleistung
jetzt aber zumindest kannst du das mit anderen access points auch aber die erlauben dir das
in der regel nicht wenn du die region auf deutschland einstellst und das hat ja auch
seinen sinn warum wir das nicht können weil das darfst du hier nicht es hindert dich
natürlich keiner dran deinen access point auf eine andere region einzustellen dann können
die das auch der brian sagt bin gerade dabei eine grafik an meiner vm durchzureichen
er aber unify kann so kann man kann es auch mit dem
unify oder mit dem mit hier mit dem ubiquity access point kannst du auch mehr senden als
in deutschland erlaubt ist wenn es auf eine andere region umstellt aber die frage ist
halt ob man das machen sollte und man davon abgesehen ja dein handy und so müsste das
ja dann auch machen bei access point ist das eine da muss ja das zeug auch empfangen ja
also ich würde es nicht machen ich würde eher gucken dass ich einfach mehrere access
points aufstelle und im zweifelsfall halt auch mal ein repeater wenn es gar nicht anders
geht und bei repeater immer so ein bisschen sache meistens um dich lahm macht hast du
in ihr wireless kopfhörer nein ich habe over over ihr wireless kopfhörer die frage ist
wer kontrolliert eine falsche einstellung wahrscheinlich wirst du damit überhaupt keine
probleme haben wenn sich im raum hält wird sich wahrscheinlich keiner abfacken das muss
erst mal jemand merken und dann muss er dich bei wer ist denn das überhaupt wer dafür
zuständig ist ich weiß es gar nicht muss er erstmal rumstehen kann aber man muss sich
mal überlegen du profitierst davon die bundes wahrscheinlich die bundesnetzagentur ja du
profitierst auch davon dass das niemand macht weil stell dir mal vor es würde jeder auf
die forgaben scheißen das ist bei einem shared medium wie luft ja ziemlich kacke
denn das luft ist ein shared medium wie willst du ein wlan sonst bezeichnen
wlan kabel ja ich würde das nicht machen selbst wenn ich für recht unwahrscheinlich
halte dass da was passiert wie gesagt wenn da zu viele leute mit rumsauen ist halt auch
kacke
sondern ich habe übelst hunger ich glaube ich gehe jetzt auf und futter noch den restlichen
restliche pizza die ich hab wir haben leider nichts von dem gemacht was wir heute vor hatten
aber wir haben schön geschwätzt mit dem chat so wie das sein muss wir sehen uns machts
gut zu bis dann